good afternoon ladies and gentlemen
welcome to the white coat ceremony for
the class of 2014 it was a pleasure to
meet many of you this morning as we had
an orientation session for the students
and families this is the formal welcome
for this class for your children
important others to the profession this
is an opportunity for us to tell them
that they are part of the profession now
and unless they do something that's
genuinely inappropriate they will stay
part of the profession we intend to
treat your children you're important
others your spouse's with dignity and
respect even though we will demand much
from them at this time I would like you
to please rise and welcome the class of
please be seated
now that we have the class of 2014 with
this welcome to you as well this is your
formal induction if you will into the
profession your parents have these
little souvenir programs out there that
you'll get to see later in here is the
story of what this white coat symbolizes
the white coat symbolizes the spirit of
a contract of trust between society and
the healthcare practitioner in part
healing reflects the trust and
confidence of the patient in their
chosen doctor or their dentist or
physician donning the white coat is
symbolic of entry into the health
professions and the sensitivity to
aseptic conditions the white coat also
implies a special knowledge attained at
great personal cost in time study
resources and duress
the white coat is also seen as an
affirmation of life
as opposed to the black coats of the
1800s physicians and their waste coats
when they attended the deathbed and
during the times of the Black Plague the
universal connotations of white include
innocence purity faithfulness safety and
more and this is so in Judaism Buddhism
Islam Hinduism Christianity and other
world major religions white in Latin is
candor a safe and comforting quality
patients very much seek in their doctor
the white coat also conveys the contract
between patients and doctor often
reduced to written permissions today
granting the caregiver the privilege to
touch the patient as part of providing
care respect these sacred trusts
look and act like the doctor you would
want to care for you and your family
never act in a manner which would darken
or damage this symbol of all that exists
between us and our patients
welcome to the health professions were
the white coat with respect and humility
at this time I would like to introduce
our Dean IRA be laughter
good afternoon today's ceremony marks a
transition for you and certainly for
your families as well as for us today we
officially welcome you to Columbia
University to the Columbia University
Medical Center and to the healing
profession the tradition of the white
coat as you just heard actually began
here at Columbia at the College of
Physicians and Surgeons and it's been
adopted by most medical schools and some
dental schools as well this is the 15th
year that we here at the dental school
have had our white coat ceremony family
medical students have traditionally been
welcomed to the profession at the time
of graduation one appoint that at the
time of graduation four years from now
today's ceremony changes that concept
and by welcoming you to the profession
at the beginning of dental school and
recognizes that professionalization and
professionalism begins as you begin your
training as you take on important
responsibilities and as you become
someone who is responsible excuse me
responsible for the care of others the
academic world is filled with customs
and ceremonies but this event has more
significance than others the white coat
ceremony welcomes you when you begin
your healthcare career not when you
ended this is more than just symbolic
rather it is a pact between us between
the faculty and between the students
that we are professional colleagues I
hope that you leave here today with
three thoughts that these thoughts stay
with you throughout your professional
career first dentistry and medicine are
healing professions and have been given
certain special responsibilities by
society second you must learn that's
what society expects of you in that new
role and third you have the public trust
and let me just speak briefly about each
of these points first the specialized
education that you receive is given to
no one other than dentists and that the
cost of the specialized knowledge the
public allows us to regulate ourselves
we regulate ourselves while society set
certain boundaries this is nonetheless a
tremendous responsibility and implies
obviously a pact on our side second how
does one behave as a professional person
there is no single course that teaches
that true
but you'll receive a four year
curriculum in ethics and professionalism
these seminars emphasize situations in
which there is no correct or incorrect
answers and I think dr. dr. Davis and I
will begin that process with you
tomorrow but rather you're presented
with situations and it requires more
than basic knowledge of science or of
clinical care really what it requires is
professional behavior and I think it's
important for me to emphasize that
compassion and an ethical compass
certainly a properly set as ethical
compass
our two traits that will serve you well
lastly if you achieve the public trust
society will reward you with a special
place in the community and as evidenced
by opinion polls you as a dentist will
review is particularly trustworthy by
the by the public the process of
becoming a professional person is
dependent in part on the curriculum
during the next four years you will also
learn informally and really what is the
extended curriculum by watching your
instructors in class by attending
professional meetings and interacting
with professionals both within the
dental profession and outside the dental
profession we believe the environment
here is particularly well suited to
develop your sense of being a
professional the dawning of a white coat
is a statement by us and by you that you
have entered a new stage of your life
your responsibilities have increased and
you are viewed differently by family
friends and the community this is a
journey and we certainly welcome that we
are taking or very happy that we are
taking the first steps with you
congratulations and again welcome to
Columbia
Thank You Tina lobster this time I'd
like to bring up someone who I have
known for a long time who attained her
DDS here our pediatric dentistry
training here her orthodontic training
here and is currently serving as the
president of our Association of dental
alumni and has offices here in Manhattan
dr. Margo Jaffe
it is my pleasure today to speak to you
on behalf of the columbia dental the
Columbia's dental medicine school and
the Alumni Association and personally
welcome the class of 2014 into our
Columbia family additionally I want to
thank the families who are here to
support and send their emerging adult
children off on an exciting
educationally challenging and ambitious
endeavor you represent the best and
brightest college graduates the pathway
is arduous but the process and wealth of
knowledge that you will acquire in the
next four years will be well worth the
effort we are excited to participate in
your graduate education our alumni are
active in every facet of the school in
teaching mentoring admissions career
placement research long-range planning
publishing lecturing global outreach
fundraising etc these activities
maximize your learning experience and
fulfill the school's vision and mission
statement to produce ethical productive
and highly competent dentists the alumni
association is your advocate and is here
to support you good luck
by the way dr. Jaffe doesn't know what
she's talking about she's on the
admissions committee some of you were
interviewed by her so she speaks of what
she knows next I'd like to bring forward
someone who also is an alumnus of the
school who has a fabulous practice in
Midtown who is actually the chairman of
the American College of dentists for New
York the American College of dentists is
an honorary Society
you have to be nominated by several of
your colleagues you can't have to join
the people who are elected to the
American College of dentists are those
who are the best and the brightest of
the profession and it's a national
organization and dr. Roberts is the
chairman of the New York section
Jonathan
as chair of the New York section of the
American College of dentists I would
like to welcome all of you to this very
special event the white coat ceremony we
in the American College are very pleased
to be able to support this event it is
really my personal pleasure to welcome
you the students of the class of 2014 as
my new professional colleagues I would
also like to welcome the parents without
whom there would be no class of 2014
let me take a few moments to share the
American College of dentists with you
the American College is the oldest
National honorary organization for
dentists it was founded in 1920 in
response the serious problems facing the
profession not unlike many of the
challenges that we face today it was
group of visionary leaders who believe
dentistry must look beyond today and
plan for the future the college is
comprised of dentists who have
exemplified excellence through their
outstanding leadership and exceptional
contributions to dentistry and society
membership as dr. Davis mentioned is by
invitation only using a confidential
peer review process about 3.5 percent of
the dentists our fellows of all dentists
are Fellows of the American College the
mission of the college is to advance
excellence ethics professionalism and
leadership in dentistry many of your
Dean's administrators and teachers are
Fellows of the college you're charged
today then becomes one of being a
professional as of today you will be
held to a higher level of ethical and
professional behavior do not assume that
simply sitting back and being
participant makes you a true
professional we do not simply exchange
goods and services a true professional
places patients interests first and
foremost
respects patients for their unique needs
values has integrity is honest is
competent strives to improve personally
strives to improve the profession by
giving back through teaching involvement
in professional groups the community and
yes even financial support but above all
a professional is ethical without high
ethical standards you cannot be a true
professional a lifelong process begins
today I look forward to joining you on
this journey
want to just take a moment now since dr.
Roberts has spoken to acknowledged who's
supporting the the luncheon today and
the activities of the day it is the
American College of dentists it's also
Procter & Gamble's oral health division
and they have a representative with us
Rebecca Van Horne if you just stand up
so they can see who you are
we very much appreciate the help of
these two organizations and having this
event the keynote address to you is
brought by dr. David Albert dr. Albert
has been on this faculty a good long
time he's actually older than he looks
he has been someone however who I have
seen personally stimulate our students
to think whether discussing what causes
cavities Keri ology why smoking is a
really truly public evil and how to help
patients get over it many other things
understanding what third parties do how
the insurance companies can or might
want to affect what you do for your
patients and their relationship you have
these are all part of the areas he
covers in the curriculum so trust me
class of 2014 you will come to know dr.
David Albert it is my pleasure to
introduce him to you as the keynote
speaker for our white white coat
ceremony today thank you
Thank You Dean lamb stir for the
invitation to speak today Dean Davis
thank you for your kind introduction
good afternoon and welcome to students
your families and friends to Columbia
University and the College of Dental
Medicine it is an honor to be here today
to speak to the first-year class about
the white coat tradition as you begin
dental school it is worthwhile to
reflect upon why you have chosen
dentistry as your career you no doubt
recall your essay when you apply to
dental school
remember the section where you describe
the reasons you want to be a dentist my
advice to you is to go back to that
essay and copy that line down put it in
your wallet periodically read and repeat
that line it is no doubt the essence of
what you are trying to achieve as a
professional hold that thought and apply
it to your patient care use it to set a
standard that you never stray from
maintain that bond with your patients
never go astray from the path and you
will fulfill the goals you've set for
yourself and your obligation to your
patients as a dentist the trust and the
professional relationships that you
establish with your patients will change
you the white coat represents many
things dr. Arnold Gold established the
white coat ceremony as the Dean
mentioned here at the College of
Physicians and Surgeons back in 1993 he
stressed that the ceremony should
transmit the message that doctors should
care as well as cure it represents both
great opportunities and great
responsibilities the enveloping with the
white coat is an experience that
underscores the bonding process you will
have with the professional community and
the obligation you have to your patients
and society first congratulations on
your acceptance to the Columbia family
as you start your first week at the
College of Dental Medicine you join a
distinguished group of alumni who like
you enter the halls of the College of
Dental Medicine for a four-year Trek
that will educate and fascinate you
embrace the education as there are many
many opportunities to learn and grow
at this esteemed institution these are
four years that will shape your future
and set the foundation for your
professional careers you are embarking
on a journey that will allow you to
become a dentist and a full member of
the profession the ceremony is intended
to impress upon you the importance of
the doctor-patient relationship it
encourages you to accept the obligations
inherent in the practice of medicine and
dentistry and emphasizes the importance
of compassionate and professionalism in
your lives some of you may be wondering
if you have what it takes to learn all
that is required to be a competent
dentist all of you have exceptional
credentials and we're chosen because
your abilities will lead you to succeed
in excel within the dental school
environment your undergraduate college
performance has been it's outstanding
the class is quite diverse some of you
will have already obtained advanced
degrees while others have been involved
in research or an industry and business
this the exceptional curriculum the
exceptionally new curriculum at CDM is
designed to train you to be an exemplary
dentist and outstanding clinician you
will be well-prepared to pass the
national boards and to show proficiency
on your licensing boards through the
excellence of its graduates the College
of Dental Medicine builds its reputation
the accomplishments of our graduates are
renowned the performance of our recent
graduates in postdoctoral education
programs and these include advanced
education and general dentistry programs
general practice residency programs oral
surgery programs orthodontic programs
public health programs pediatric
dentistry and the daunting and
prosthodontics programs all the
performances of our students in those
programs are exceptional the cause of
the consistent quality and excellence of
our graduate programs will seek your
applications CDM is the leader in
postdoctoral education acceptances in
the United States as you Don your white
coats never forget that you will be
setting the standard for the profession
and yourself never accept mediocrity set
the standard Columbia graduates and
faculty have set the standard for the
dental profession many of you will also
become renowned as clinicians
the missions researchers and leaders who
will change the face of Dentistry in the
direction of healthcare thank you I want
to take this opportunity to mention
several Colombians at the College of
Dental Medicine who have changed the
profession there are many many like them
you too can aspire to lead and change
the profession I want to start with a
biochemist here at Columbia named
William God's he was a remarkable
columbia biochemist and researcher dr.
guys was interested in dental medicine I
was on dental education science and
clinical applications in 1926 as part of
a series of studies on professional
education in the United States funded by
the Carnegie Foundation for the
Advancement of teaching dr. guys
published a landmark report that
established the importance of dentistry
is a healing science and as an essential
component of higher education in the
Health Professions the guys report
dental education in the United States
and Canada took five years to research
and write it consists of 250 pages of
text and more than 400 pages of
appendices dr. guys visited every dental
school in the United States and writing
this report the dental education system
that you are entering today was in large
part shaped by the guys report another
graduate of this school dr. Erwin Mendel
graduated in 1945 he established the
gold standard for research and teaching
and shifted the focus of dentistry from
repair to prevention he has authored
more than 200 scientific articles in 17
books or book chapters he conducted
pioneer research on the role of dental
plaque and tooth decay and periodontal
disease and is also known for studies of
salivary composition as it relates to
dental disease and systemic disease he
won the American Dental Association's
award for excellence in dental research
in 1985 when he retired he was the CDM
dean for research I met Aaron in 1987 it
was his career and inspiration that led
me to Columbia and into academics and
research you will find many
inspirational faculty members of this
institution and within the other schools
of Columbia University the last graduate
of the school that I want to mention is
it
just named dr. Lawrence Tabak dr. Tabak
graduated in 1977 from the College of
Dental Medicine he has been at the
forefront of demo research since his
student days at Columbia currently he's
director of the National Institutes of
dental and craniofacial research at the
National Institutes of Health dr. Taber
Tabak has published extensively on the
structure biosynthesis and function of
salivary mucins the pathogenesis of
salary gland disease and dysfunction and
the use of saliva as a diagnostic fluid
just last week dr. Tabak was appointed
as the new principal deputy director of
the National Institutes of Health
last year he oversaw the dispersal of
NIH is ten billion dollars in stimulus
funds all remarkable accomplishments for
me I am the child of immigrants to the
United States my parents came to this
country of refugees and survivors of the
Holocaust from Europe following World
War two for them the health professions
particularly academia and research were
the essence of the American dream for
their children I came to the College of
Dental Medicine in 1987 I've had a
rewarding career that has been a blend
of practice teaching research and
community leadership and activism my
clinical practice is part of the
Presbyterian of New York Presbyterian
Hospital where I am the medical and
dental director of a comprehensive
geriatric clinic it is a practice model
that I hope we will see more of and need
more of in the future the complex
medical histories and the prevalence of
polypharmacy to treat chronic diseases
in the elderly make integration of
medical and dental practices sensible we
are able to do this here at Columbia and
our Hospital there are times when you
will practice and provide a service that
has a profound impact on a patient's
life you'll acquire skills over the next
four years to diagnose and treat the
oral health and improve the overall
well-being of your patients I would like
to describe a recent case in my practice
as an example of the impact you can have
on a patient's life the case involved an
85 year old patient who had suffered
from chronic headaches for most of her
adult life she never smiled during her
visits and expressed the discomfort to
me repeatedly as
well as to her physician social worker
and psychiatrist I remade her partial
dentures but this had no impact on her
chronic headaches she was referred by
her physician to her neurologist who
after extensive testing that included CT
scans ruled out neurological reasons for
the chronic headaches at our periodic
examination I decided to fabricate an
occlusal nightclub the wear on the
patient's teeth did not appear to be the
result of bruxing or grinding but rather
from a lifetime of normal attrition and
wear for an 85 year old during for a
follow-up visit with her social worker I
was called on the phone and informed
that the patient had come in and her
pain was gone for the first time she was
smiling the night guard had worked at
the patient's next visit I was given a
bear hug from a grateful patient and
you'd have to see this patient she's
about 65 pounds and about 4 foot 10 in
height and to get a bear hug from this
from this patient made my day made my
month you will experience many treatment
successes like this to be successful
with difficult cases it is important to
be confident constantly inquire and to
explore all the options available to you
this will build your treatment acumen
and give you the confidence to build
your professional career at other times
treatment successes can be very very
difficult how to handle these difficult
cases and manage the patient will be a
challenge I am currently treating a
longtime patient was diagnosed with
leukemia she is 72 years old following
radiation and chemotherapy she developed
oral mucositis a painful condition that
is very difficult to treat the patient
has lost a lot of weight and she cannot
eat well because of the pain the only
treatment for this condition is
palliative the patient comes to me
expecting an answer why do I have this
pain can't you make it go away I have
consulted with her oncologist I have
battled with her insurance company to
cover the lidocaine elixir that I want
to prescribe to palliate the pain
however I cannot make the situation
better I respond to calls from her
children and social worker asking me why
I'm not able to make her better these
are the difficult cases that require you
to call on all your professional
Gill's to provide guidance for your
patients you reach down and provide
empathy and understanding however in
some situations you cannot provide a
cure I will see you this year as course
director in my carry ology dental
infectious diseases course in January
and in my oral health care delivery
course in the third year my research
focuses on clinician and dentist
adoption of guidelines in practice at
CDM you will be encouraged to be
inquisitive and question the science and
guidelines that the profession and oral
health infrastructure are established
upon in my oral health care delivery
course that I teach with dr. Carol Coons
L a behavioral scientist that you get to
know over the next four years I
encourage students to question the basis
of treatment Plato said all opinions
without scientific base are useless as
you start your careers always examine
the scientific basis of treatments and
practices it is through your inquiry and
questioning that practice is developed
and mature and the profession moves
forward when you are seeing patients ten
years from now they will expect you that
when they will expect that you are
practicing according to 2020 guidelines
not the 2010 guidelines you learned at
Columbia don't forget the importance of
setting the standard that I mentioned
earlier continue to be inquisitive and
establish yourself in a pattern of
lifelong learning
the great philosopher Whoopi Goldberg
stated on her show the view if you are
not taking care of your mouth then you
are not taking care of your whole body
and it will kill you unfortunately in
the United States many Americans did not
have access to dental services part of
being a professional is community
service or volunteering give back to
your community their remarkable effort
was started several years ago by dental
and medical students at the College of
Dental Medicine and in the College of
the Physicians and Surgeons College a
student-run volunteer clinic in Central
Harlem was established to provide
services to the homeless many of you
will traverse the world to obtain
experiences treating patients in
countries in need of oral healthcare
use the skills you learn here at
Columbia and in your varied experiences
to improve the oral health of your
communities I would like to finish with
a quotation from President Obama that he
delivered at the University of Chicago
School of Medicine it's only when you
hitch your wagon to something larger
than yourself that you will realize your
true potential you will look back on
your years here at Columbia with
fondness for the knowledge you guarded
and cherish the many interactions you
will establish with your faculty and
peers I wish you success in your
training and in your life as a dentist
you are the future of the profession
thank you
thank you very much dr. Albert a couple
of notes at this point two things are
being presented to you as well when you
come up for your white coats one is a
pin for the College of Dental Medicine
that you can wear on your white coat or
other attire if you wish and the other
is from the Alumni Association these
tote bags the people who will present
you these up here dr. Laureen zoo bre
for admissions will present the pin and
dr. renee look back who is class of o2
here DDS class of o4 endodontics will
present you on behalf the Alumni
Association
with these bags I'm going to bring up
the members of the class eight at a time
just step forward up to the edge of the
stage I'm going to introduce now the
people who will present the coats to you
help you put them on now I know the
parents would like pictures we're going
to keep them all up here at the end so
you can take pictures
other than stepping on each other in the
eye ways or maybe tripping the people
coming to get the white coats because
it's a little tight for that here so if
you kind of hold off in the photographs
to the end we'd appreciate it does I
call your name please if you will the
coat presenters come to the stage here
beginning with our vice dean for
academic affairs dr. Letty moths Allen
time
dr. Ronnie Myers is our vice dean for
administrative affairs and in charge of
our clinical operations press of 79 with
dr. Roberts
dr. Margot Jaffe whom you have met our
Alumni Association president dr. Dennis
Mitchell who also has the mph degree is
a senior associate dean for diversity
and multicultural affairs dr. Madelyn
Ginsburg assistant clinical professor of
Dental Medicine
dr. Jonathan Roberts whom you have met
Glenn again a classmate class of 79 if
dr. Meyers and they still speak to each
other
dr. Shantanu law who heads our
pre-doctoral pediatric dentistry oh five
and also did his Pediatrics here dr. law
I could have dr. zubr II and dr. Lynne
theft and one more coat presenter who is
the course director of the dental
Anatomy and occlusion course that you
will be in this Paul dr. Stanley Freeman
I promise to do my best to pronounce
your names
I have tried mightily to understand that
and not mess them up please forgive me
if I do and parents don't hurt me
the first eight individuals Bobby I'm
Salem the Yaakov Barak just step
straight forward there in front of the
presenter please by Austin Austin by a
DD Bharat Kumar ABI Brecker Lance Carter
Alejandro Costanzo jose castillo
you know
thank you
off to the side and receive your PIN
wing Chen Brian Chung
Wesley choy Alexandra Dell finer Dell
finer Brandon Duncan Shannon Eddie Eli
Josh Eli
tamer Ezra
Scott Ewing
Andrew Ferraro Sean Francis at sushi
Bujumbura Kevin for manic Austin gall
LaRon cams a Grigory
Gelfand
Bihari
Gosha Yeshe Jeffrey had jibun de Zachary
Hirsch Tina
Jung Victor Kagan David Carr wacky David
Kim and Jung Kim
Sky's Yocum way King Basilius Kostas
Sergey Kuznetsov
Kimberly Liao Andrew
Lee Jiwon Lee Ryan Lemke
Gaeta lemon Elena
li Guang Ali Vivian Lim Rachel Lipsky
mykola Tucci Ahmad Malay Theodore
mahalik
chef jet Mesfin Lydia Mojave lien
Jenny's Moy Sehun Oh Brendan O'Rourke
omen Lego of Buddha
Angelina Peck
Kimberly Papas
Vanessa Pascoe and friends Samantha res
Alexander Rubinoff Jeffrey Reba Pasha
Cory
Michael Shapiro marina
serova Reuben Sherman
Philip shin Dana szilgyi Joshua Stefan
Joseph Stern Inessa Doric yarn Thorson
Yin one Joseph Wang
so far almond paste
kun Wang Cindy weeson filled Joshua
Logan booth Bethany Wang Jake Wong Andy
Sheng and Jessica Zillow
Thank You coders please be seated
unless I'm mistaken all the coats
actually fit this time it's pretty good
because we're making wild guesses having
never won one of these before right
congratulations to the class of 2014 and
now the person who almost knew to stay
here I will call our vice dean for
closing remarks vice dean al any moss
salad tine GDS PhD who I'm sure has real
words of wisdom and to think dr. Davis
was one of my students all right
the Dean and I have a half a gig he has
opening remarks I have closing remarks
it seemed to do this very well there's
in this ceremony that we have just had
there is a great deal of symbolism we
have welcomed you as we have said to as
the newest professors the newest members
nevermind
of the dental profession this will take
a little longer okay this is a trusted
profession as was symbolized by the
white coat which has a distinct code of
ethics and rules of behavior and so as
of today in a very real sense
expectations of your behavior have
changed may not feel that way yet but I
have your medical colleagues take a
centuries-old both of Hippocrates and in
many ways the promise you have made or
you will make actually that tomorrow is
modeled on that oath in a real sense by
entering a healing profession you have
now stopped being a member of the
general public you are assuming
important duties along with the
privileges and they are good privileges
that come with being a member of this
profession and these duties begin this
week first and foremost your actions
from now on will be centered on your
future patients
and as we kind of laughingly reminded
ourselves this morning until now you
have studied in self-centered manner you
may have hoped to pass a course by
cramming or you may have done just
enough to squeak by but now you're no
longer studying for yourself you or your
patients a dedication to learning both
the theoretical basis of the industry
the biomechanical social behavior as
well as the clinical sciences and the
clinical skill to become the best
practitioner possible to work just to
pass a course is no longer acceptable
and so this means that the college
students question how much am I
responsible for question mark is now
irrelevant since it can only be answered
with everything no patient wants to be
treated by a dentist who considers a
level of 65% knowledge or skill adequate
you wouldn't I wouldn't your patients
know not you or the patient's lifelong
learning to maintain your skills in the
best way possible in the near future you
will find that you owe your patients
your complete dedication in time and
effort even if that may be inconvenient
for your personal schedule you are now
expected to behave professionally and
according to the ethical code of conduct
of your profession in your personal
behavior as well as in self-policing
activity that the profession requires as
will be explained to you tomorrow today
is a joyful day we had great pleasure
putting the white coats on you you've
just become the youngest members of our
profession our most junior colleagues
welcome
and she still has good a teacher she was
when she straightened me out so be aware
of that
be ready thank you all for coming to our
ceremony today as I said we will now ask
all of you in these new white coats if
you'll assemble up on here
mr. McAndrew who is our AV chairperson
if you will well tell you how he wants
to set you up for photographs and
friends and family are welcome to take
photos as well please no elbowing
punching hitting kicking or biting my
own pediatric dentist and I will stop
you all right thank you again
congratulations in the class Thank You
PNG in American College
you